>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Sue Vita: Good
evening, everyone.
Thank you for coming tonight.
My name is Susan Vita,
and I'm the Chief
of the Music Division
here at the Library.
It is my pleasure to welcome
you tonight to the latest
in our ongoing collaborative
lecture series
with the American
Musicological Society.
This series has been
going strong
since the inaugural
lecture by Judith Tick
on Ruth Crawford Seeger
probably 10 years ago.
And we are pleased to
co-sponsor the series
which highlights
research that was done
in the Music Division
either in-house or online.
Tonight's lecture by Dr. Daniel
Callahan will explore the
physicality of Leonard
Bernstein's
conflicting practices.
Sorry, conducting practices.
Probably both.
And fits right in with
the worldwide celebration
of Bernstein's centenary
this year.
Somebody told me that there are
20 events celebrating Bernstein
this week, so I'm glad that
you all chose ours, and --
as you know, the Library
of Congress holds the
Leonard Bernstein Collection
which contains 400,000 items.
This AMS Lecture is part
of a week-long series
of events looking at
many different aspects
of the American icon.
We hope that you will join us
for our other events as well
which include a screening of On
the Waterfront, on Thursday,
a concert on Friday of known
and unknow Bernstein songs
featuring Michael Barrett
and a fantastic team
of young singers.
I'm just really looking
forward to that,
and another all-day
affair on Saturday,
which is not the Royal
Wedding [laughter],
in which we will have six
speakers and performers talking
about all things Bernstein.
We will also have a
selection of the treasures
from the Bernstein
collection that will be
on display all day long, and
we hope to see you there.
While there is nothing
like being there in person,
one great thing about
the AMS Library
of Congress partnership is
that we record the lectures
for future webcasts on the
Library's website and YouTube.
And the lectures of the
talented scholars selected
for the series are available for
all to enjoy around the world.
Before Dr. Callahan speaks,
I'd like to introduce
Martha Feldman,
the Mable Green Meyers Professor
of Music and the Humanities
at the College -- in the College
at the University of Chicago.
Professor Feldman
is the President
of the American Musicological
Society
and will be offering her
greetings from the Society.
So thank you all again for
joining us this evening
and please join me in
welcoming Professor Feldman.
[ Applause ]
>> Martha Feldman: It's really
an enormous pleasure to be here
and to be able to introduce an
AMS Library of Congress Lecturer
at this amazing great
institution
where I actually carried
out dissertation research
as an avid, very zealous PhD
student quite some time ago,
decades ago.
I won't say how many.
Like many AMS members,
I've returned
to the Library's collections
in music and have worked
in other areas of the Library
many times over the years
in person, by correspondence,
and now digitally as well.
So it's very, very rewarding
to be able to participate
in this collaboration during
my tenure as AMS President.
I want to thank very sincerely
the staff who have helped
with this -- David Plyler,
Kate Miller, Ben Walsh,
and, of course Susan Vita.
And with that, let me just say
that I'm particularly happy
and honored to introduce
tonight's speaker,
Professor Daniel Callahan, a
valued colleague in musicology
and a dear friend as well.
Daniel earned his BA at
NYU and his MA, M.Phil.,
and PhD at Columbia University,
the last of those in 2012.
Since 2014, Daniel has been
Assistant Professor of Music
at Boston College where he
teaches courses that range
from Aesthetics, Empathy, and
Ethics to Modernism in Dance.
Before that, he was the Mellon
Postdoctoral Fellow and Lecturer
in Music in the Humanities
at the University of Chicago,
a position into which I was
lucky enough to have hired him
in 2012 when chairing
my department,
that's before we were
friends, and where he taught
for two years Undergraduate
and Graduate Courses.
He taught wonderful
courses on music video,
Soundies to YouTube,
and Choreomusicalities,
and collaborations
between different composers
and choreographers, and things
that none of us were doing
and none of us had, in
some cases, even heard of.
A cellist and dancer himself,
Daniel has given an
extraordinary number
of professional papers on topics
that stretch from Bernstein,
Copeland, and John Cage, to
Mullermae [assumed spelling],
1930's cartoons, Maersk
Cunningham, Nijinsky, Ted Shawn
and his Men Dancers,
and in approaches
that suture together the
concerns of music, dance,
and image with those of
gay aesthetics and desire.
Daniel Callahan is the recipient
of many grants, fellowships,
and awards in addition
to the Mellon Postdoc
that I mentioned earlier.
He's won a Whiting Dissertation
Completion Fellowship,
the Selma Jeanne Cohen
Award from the Society
of Dance History
Scholars, and various awards
from Boston College,
Columbia, and AMS.
This summer we'll
see the publication
of Daniel's ambitious and
much anticipated article
for the Journal of the American
Musicological Society entitled,
"The Gay Divorce of Music
and Dance, Choreomusicality,
and the Early Works
of Cage-Cunningham,"
which adduces new archival
and performative evidence
for the early collaborations of
John Cage and Merce Cunningham,
to argue that music and
dance were not divided
in their early years but
were interrelated intimately,
especially through gay critiques
of heterosexual marriage.
Given that Daniel has
established himself
in public presentations as an
intellect to be reckoned with,
there's reason for great
excitement about his book
in progress, The Dancer From
the Music, Choreomusicalities
in American Modern Dance which
is bound to set American music
and dance studies
on a new course.
Please join me in welcoming
Professor Daniel Callahan
in his AMS Library of
Congress lecture entitled
"Bernstein Conducting Himself."
[ Applause ]
>> Daniel M. Callahan:
Thank all of you for coming.
Thank you, Susan Vita, our Chief
Librarian of Music Division,
thank you Martha Feldman
for that incredibly
generous introduction.
I wasn't sure who you were
talking about some part of that,
and also for your exemplary
leadership as President
of the American Musicological
Society, and for being a mentor
and friend to me for
these past six years.
Words to not being to
express how honored I am
to share my research with
all of you today here
at the Library of Congress.
In September, 2011,
during my final year
of writing my dissertation
on music and modern dance,
I came to the Library's
Music Division
to research what had then been
a long brewing side project,
"The Complicated Gestation of
Bernstein's Westside Story."
I had intended to stay in
Washington, D.C. for just a week
and then go back to my
dissertation in New York.
That was the plan.
The Music Division's
Senior Music Specialist,
Mark Eden Horowitz, welcomed me.
He talked with my about
my research and alerted me
that hundred and
hundreds of letters
in the personal correspondence
of Leonard Bernstein,
letters that had previously
been sealed and unavailable
to researchers, had very
recently been unsealed and were
in the midst of being processed.
Much to the chagrin
of my then boyfriend
and my dissertation advisers
my one-week stay turned
into three weeks.
Since that time, my side
project has now turned
into a second book project.
For that I want to thank
Mark Eden Horowitz,
who is one of the national
treasures here at the Library
of Congress, along
with the amazing staff
who helped make today
possible, especially Kate Miller
and David Pylar [assumed
spelling], and in the back,
Jay Ken Lock and Mike
Terpin [assumed spelling]
on audio visual.
We had a near meltdown
earlier and they saved the day.
Like the 90-degree weather
in Washington, D.C. today,
Leonard Bernstein is hot.
You do not need a
musicologist to tell you this.
Just look at my title
slide's photograph of him
after a concert [laughter].
Backstage in 1951, a
photograph taken by Ruth Orkin
and held here in the
Library of Congress,
this massive Leonard
Bernstein collection.
If that doesn't convince you,
maybe he's not your type,
consider the myriad
concerts and special events
that are taking place around the
globe this year in celebration
of Bernstein's centennial.
If you are a classical
music fan, the Bernstein
at 100 Events, which
are occurring
at a local symphony orchestra
near you, are not news.
If you are not a classical music
fan, and perhaps joining us
on YouTube, and have
just stumbled upon this,
you still might not be
convinced that Bernstein is hot.
In that case, I look to
Hollywood and I ask you
to consider the news that came
out two weeks ago today --
"Jake Gyllenhaal Plays
Music Icon Leonard Bernstein
in Cary Fukunago-Helmed 'The
American'" We have a kind
of famous actor who really
wants an Oscar who's also a bit
of a heartthrob agreeing to play
Leonard Bernstein on screen.
On that very same day,
May 1st, on Netflix,
former Saturday
Night Live writer,
John Mulaney released his
stand-up special Cape
Gorgeous .
Within six minutes into his
routine, Mulaney relates how,
when he was 12 years old,
his father brought up
and made Leonard
Bernstein the center
of what might be the world's
most mysterious sex talk.
Instead of butchering the joke,
I will just direct
you to Netflix.
Finally, only a few days
ago, it was announced
that Bradley Cooper
will also star in,
and in this case direct, a
Leonard Bernstein biopic.
So, the question is not
whether or not Bernstein is hot.
The question is now, "Wer
Wird Bernstein Besser
Spielen [laughter]?"
Who will be better at playing
Leonard Bernstein on screen?
As two of Hollywood's leading
men wish to embody him,
it's kind of not surprising.
Leonard Bernstein made
embodying himself look
so easy, so smart, so musical.
Take, for example,
this, my first clip
from a Young People's
Concert , nationally televised
in 1960 called "Who
is Gustav Mahler?
I like to imagine my
mother back in Chicago,
age eight in Ukrainian village,
perhaps my first generation
grandparents also watching
Bernstein in their living room.
So let's just watch this now.
[ Music ]
>> Now, was
that heartbroken-sounding
music the real Mahler?
Or is the other happy
sleigh bell music?
No, they're both Mahler.
They're the voices of the two
different people inside him.
>> Daniel M. Callahan:
If the real Mahler had two
different people inside him,
according to Leonard Bernstein,
one might very well wonder,
how many different people
were inside the real
Leonard Bernstein?
And how will any actor, even one
as talented as Jake Gyllenhaal
or Bradley Cooper, play him
and convey this on screen --
conductor, composer, pianist,
writer, educator, activist,
television celebrity,
husband to his wife, Felicia,
father to three children,
lover to countless men,
and devoted friend.
Bernstein sought to be the
best in all possible worlds.
Both during and after
his life, critics
and biographers diagnosed
him as a precocious genius
who squandered his talent
because of an inability
to focus on a single activity.
In the past decade, multiple
scholars have nuanced our
understanding of Bernstein,
focused most often
on his compositions.
Today I'm excited to
share some of my research
on Bernstein's conducting,
an area that has not received
as much scholarly attention.
Like his other professional
activities,
Bernstein's conducting has had
a mixed reception among critics.
Considerable ink was
spilled in newspaper reviews
for half a century, and among
amateur lovers, both fans
and detractors of his
conducting, have been vocal
from the 1940s up to the
present, now 27 years
after his death -- 28.
Among critic practitioners
of conducting,
Bernstein is often
considered a first-rate showman
and a second-rate technician.
Take Gunther Schuller
who presents his scorched
Earth perspective on a century
of conducting his his book,
The Complete Conductor .
Schuller makes no secret of his
preference for conductors who,
like himself, quote, "Respect
rigorously the content
of a score," end quote,
so much so that, quote,
"The score becomes a kind of
sacred document," end quote.
Once one accepts Schuller's
idealization of the score,
most of his large book
seems logical enough.
Schuller's criticisms
of Bernstein most
often regard temp beat.
Usually he's too slow.
For example, Bernstein once
did conduct the andante second
movement of Brahms's First
Symphony with the quarter note
at 24 beats per minute.
While that might be a
flagrant and specific foul,
Schuller's criticism
of Bernstein is unflagging
throughout his book.
For the most part he is concise,
never exceeding a
phrase or sentence.
For example, quote, "Leonard
Bernstein was Reiner's pupil,
but one of the world's
most histrionic
and exhibitionistic conductors."
Or, Bernstein's interpretation
of Brahms's First
Symphony has quote,
"too much of an oy-vay
Weltschmerz
to be bearable," end quote.
And, quote, "Bernstein was
one of the most overrated
and adulated conductors
of recent times.
He rarely practiced what he
preached, to work in service
of the composer, a sad fact,
given his enormous basic
natural talent, musical
and conductorial-gestural."
Published in 1997,
Schuller's feeling
that Bernstein was grossly
overrated was obviously not
shared by the many
classical music lovers
who had been doing all of
that overrating for decades.
Critic John Rockwell
remembers that as a teenager
in the late 1950s he
had fierce arguments
in which he defended
Bernstein again other teenagers
who labelled his conducting,
quote, "flamboyant,"
a word that occurs
throughout discourse
about Bernstein on the podium.
I don't think teenagers
today are talking
about Bernstein's flamboyance.
Oh, this is the 1950s.
The understanding of Bernstein
as better than his critics
and in need of defense
against them was so widespread
that it could even provide a
laugh in a primetime sitcom.
In "Everyone's a Critic", a
1999 episode of Frasier ,
the character Niles Crane
is named a music critic
for a magazine [laughter].
>> How did this happen, Niles?
>>I was at a party
thrown by the publisher,
Olga Swardre [assumed spelling].
The pretentious fop who had the
job before me was there too,
spouting sheer drivel
about Leonard Bernstein.
Being polite, I kept my
tongue sheathed [laughter],
until he referred to Bernstein's
conducting as overrated.
>> I assume you pounced.
>> Like a ninja [laughter].
>> Daniel M. Callahan:
Back to Gunter Schuller.
After 479 pages, throughout
which Bernstein here
and there is consistently
criticized for failing to adhere
to various details, Schuller
finally offers, quote,
"a word about Bernstein,"
end quote.
It's actually over 500 words
in a page-conquering footnote,
following yet another
knit-picky critique
about Bernstein's
Renickderstortions [assumed
spelling] and Measure 92 of
[inaudible] Suite Number Two.
The rest of this footnote,
outlined on the slide,
is devoted to a critique
in which Schuller touches
on Bernstein's inability
to focus
on a single professional
activity as well as, quote,
"his ego-driven distortions,
exaggerations, and histrionics,
his drinking, outrageous
behavior, pursuit of the trendy
and chic, and his
bisexuality," end quote.
Schuller concludes
that Bernstein, quote,
"had very little
discipline and no shame.
And that his podium antics
and athletic exhibitionism,
although wonderful for audiences
in television," end quote,
demonstrate that he did
not put the score first.
Schuller wanted more
Beethoven, less Bernstein.
For Bernstein and his fans, the
distinction between Beethoven
and Bernstein was too
blurred to matter.
Given Bernstein's celebrity
status, it is not surprising
that discussions
of his conducting
on stage were sometimes
conflated
with his conduct off stage.
Histrionic podium antics
and athletic exhibitionism,
to quote Schuller,
"bothered him."
But so did the fact that
Bernstein, his colleague
for decades, was a less
than puritanical homosexual.
I should note that I will
refer to Bernstein as gay
and homosexual, and
not bisexual.
This is how his closest
friends refer to him.
It is also how his wife, Felicia
Montealegre, referred to him
in a letter shortly after they
were married in 1951 or 1952.
This is in the Library's
recently unsealed letters.
Quote, "You are a homosexual and
may never change," end quote.
Schuller's criticisms
betray a larger fear,
that fallible bodies
and performances can never
do justice to ideal works.
A large part of any musical
performance is not just a
musician's movements that
result in a specific sound, say,
how tight or wide a
cellist's bravado is,
but also bodily movements
and facial expressions
that are often considered
supplementary
to musical expression.
The distinction between
movements that do and movements
that don't, result in a specific
sound, become wonderfully blurry
when we consider the conductor.
And so what Schuller calls
histrionics might be worth a
closer look.
Musicians who played
under Bernstein maintain
contra Schuller
that he was not moving
for the audience.
Quote, "He certainly does not
act and gesticulate for the sake
of show," end quote, said
Viennese Violinist Hans Novak.
"He jumps about during
rehearsals
when he has no public
behind him," end quote.
Bernstein sought to
both lead the musicians
and become the music,
music that was far larger
than his five feet eight inches
and 140-something pounds.
For Bernstein, as for
the music-loving scholar,
Roland Bart, every score
became, quote, "a muscular music
in which the body itself must
transcribe what it reads.
It is the scripter, not
the receiver, end quote.
Bernstein, more than any
conductor I know spoke and wrote
of music in just this way.
Bart. when he was fully involved
in a work of music, writes that,
quote, "Every distinction
between composer, interpreter,
and auditor is abolished,
so much so that the musical
text becomes Bart's body."
Fellow musicologist and future
AMS President, Suzanne Cusack,
has written of, quote, "the
desire to know the music
as a means to physically
be that music," end quote.
This is empathy.
Today we might think of empathy
as being able to know what it's
like to be someone else,
to stand into their shoes,
to know how they feel.
So we might think of people
like nurses or Meryl Streep
or Former President
Barack Obama.
The word empathy, however,
entered the English language
only in the early 20th century
and then, as a translation of
the German aesthetic concept
of [foreign word], which
is the vitalization
of a non-living art object
through the projection
of one's own kinesthetic
self into it.
One projects oneself
into the artwork in order
to experience the
artwork dynamism,
its movement, and its form.
You basically say,
I am you to a score,
or a sculpture, or a painting.
This concept was embraced
in the 1930s by John Martin,
the first full-time dance
critic in the United States.
He believed that modern dance
offered its viewers the chance
to experience kinesthetic
empathy with the bodies
of another engaged
in choreography.
But before I come back to
modern dance, a quick note
about some older dancing.
Whether in rehearsal
or in concert,
Bernstein's body might
remined one that the word
"orchestra" derives from
the Greek "orchestra,"
orches meaning dancing place.
The part of the stage
in ancient theaters
that was nearest the audience,
where the chorus
danced and sand.
We might say that Bernstein's
conducting is a kind
of bodily scripting of the
orchestral music in front
of him, or literally
Orchesographie ,
the title of our
[inaudible] 1589 Treatise
on the Relationship Between
Dance and Music and Social Dance
as well as the word
that would morph
into choreography
two centuries later.
Although Bernstein and
his fans often speak
of his spontaneity
while conducting,
of his in the momentness, I
want to propose that we think
of Bernstein's conducting
instead as choreography.
What's more, by the end of
this talk, I hope to show
that this choreography actually
remains surprisingly consistent
from performance to performance,
sometimes even across decades.
This is not just that there
are certain standard gestures
in Bernstein's movement
vocabulary,
but repeat across scores.
There certainly are.
But also that entire set
patterns of movement repeat
with the precision that strikes
me as uncanny and noteworthy.
A larger conclusion here
is that Bernstein's body,
for all of its movement
and supposed visibility
on television, on stage, has
actually been taken for granted
and has never been that
carefully observed.
One sometimes even encounters
interpretations of the same work
that sound fairly different,
but in which Bernstein's
conducting looks
nearly identical.
Bernstein's podium
choreography for the "Rite
of Spring" is more
consistent across years,
I realized in November of 2014,
than was that of
conductor Andris Nelson's
over a three-concert-weekend
at Boston's Symphony Hall.
This was surprising but what,
if anything, did it mean?
Bernstein's choreography
on the podium registered
his empathy with the score.
It is his shameless presentation
of that empathy that represents,
perhaps, his most
unique contribution
to the art of conducting.
For Bernstein, the podium
was both a dancing place
and a safe space of sorts where,
emboldened and legitimated
by a beloved score, he could
become both the music and,
paradoxically, most himself.
From the beginning,
reviewers noticed the nearness
between Bernstein's
conducting and modern dance.
Consider Alan Downs's
rave review
of Bernstein's breakthrough
performance on Sunday,
November 14th, 1943, when
famously Bernstein stepped
in for an ailing Bruno Walter
and conducted the New York
Philharmonic at Carnegie Hall.
Downs writes, quote, "He
conducted without a baton,
justifying this by his
instinctively expressive use
of his hand and a
bodily plastic which,
if not always conservative,
was to the point,
alive and expressed
of this music.
And so understood
by the players.
Greater reserve will come later.
It would be ominous
if Mr. Bernstein had
it now," end quote.
Note that phrase,
"bodily plastic."
This refers to expressive
movement practices, like dance,
that were widespread in the
first third of the 20th century,
such as Dalcroze Eurhythmics
here with some dancers
at an early program at Peabody
and then Bernstein
on your right.
An expressive dance
or free dance,
the craze set off
by Isadora Duncan.
Although Downs doesn't
use bodily plastic
in a directly negative way, he
still suggests that this quote,
"not always conservative,"
unquote movement
is just a phase.
Opportunities to
conduct increased
when Bernstein was
named the Music Director
of the New York City
Symphony Orchestra in 1945.
So, too, the possibilities
for him to be reviewed,
and these reverences to
the choreographic nature
of his conducting would continue
throughout the rest of his life.
For example, we hear at this
chorybantic choreographies,
which include the
miming of facial gestures
of uncontrollable states."
That's Virgil Thompson
writing in '47.
And then Harold Schonberg
who kind of had it in for one
of Bernstein, wrote, quote,
"Bernstein is the
most choreographic
of all contemporary conductors."
And Schonberg again in 1953,
quote, "He rose vertically
into the air, a la Nijinsky,
and hovered there a good
15 seconds by the clock."
The two references
to choreography here
both suggest that,
as was true when the when the
word began its wider circulation
in the early 20th
century, that it was a term
that was only applied to the
more outre modernist dancing
such as that of Nijinsky.
References to Nijinsky also
portray an understanding
of Bernstein not only as
saltatory, ready to leap
out of a window on stage,
but also as unconventionally
masculine.
In his draft for his 1979 "Young
People's Concert, Ballet Birds,"
which you can see online
through the Library of Congress,
Bernstein was read to
publicly address he fact
that he had been criticized for
being too dancerly for too long.
He wrote, "Besides, after
years of reading in the papers
about my own balletic
movements on the podium,
whatever that may
mean, I probably ought
to give myself some real
ballet music to dance to,
so that the critics
can feel justified.
Right?
Eventually either
Bernstein or someone
on the Production Team decided
that airing his grievance
with the critics and
further drawing attention
to his style would not make
for good TV for children.
Eventually, Bernstein
developed a thick skin.
He was not the first conductor
on whose bodily movements
the press became fixated.
Consider, of course,
Gustav Mueller, the composer
who Bernstein famously
championed.
He was also criticized for
his conducting on the podium.
Just as some criticism
of Bernstein thinly disguises
the homophobic sentiment beneath
it, so, too, did criticism and
grotesque characterizations
of Mahler's body sometimes
reveal antisemitism.
Over his career, Mahler's
conducting gestures became
more reserved.
According to critics, he used
less of the space around him
on the podium and his affected
presentations were less dynamic
with time.
Bernstein's development
as a conductor took the
exact opposite course.
At the Curtis Institute in 1939,
Conductor Fritz Reiner tried
to instill in Bernstein
a sense of discipline,
an obsessive attention to
detail, control over all parts
of the score, and a
relative economy of gesture.
This was the opposite
of the more emotion
and motion-filled example
of the training Bernstein
was receiving simultaneously
under Koussevitzky in summers
at the Berkshire Music
Center, today Tanglewood.
But the real impetus
for Bernstein's large,
very physical conducting
came from the example
of Dimitri Mitropoulos.
Mitropoulos awakened in your
Bernstein passions both musical
and sexual, even if they
were never consummated
between the two men.
We can't be sure.
In January, 1937, during his
sophomore year of college
at Harvard, Bernstein
met Mitropoulos.
The conductor immediately
saw something special
in the young man and
invited him to his rehearsals
for his American debut with
the Boston Symphony Orchestra.
By all accounts, Bernstein's
own, those of his friends,
letters to others, the
young Bernstein was dazzled
by Mitropoulos's conducting
which included Ravel's Rhapsody
Espanol and Schumann's Second
Symphony .
Metropoulos took Bernstein and
his friend Mildred to a café
after the rehearsal they
were invited to watch,
and there he fed the young
man an oyster off of his fork.
And then, the setting
intimacy was followed
by Mitropoulos's just
as sudden departure.
It all upturned the
young Bernstein's world.
Over a year after their first
meeting in 1938, Bernstein wrote
about his relationship
with Mitropoulos,
but renamed him Eros
Mavro [assumed spelling]
in a very thinly-veiled
autobiographical short story
titled, The Occult .
Looking at that story, which
he wrote for a writing course
at Harvard, what
Bernstein seems to have seen
in Mitropoulos was a man
who used his body fully
and without shame.
Carl, as Bernstein renames
himself in the story,
observes the conductor in
rehearsal and is stunned.
While conducting Eros Mavro
rises up and falls back
down onto the stool
on the podium.
He breaks the stool, but
he never stops conducting.
Eros Mavro jumps up and
then he crashes down again,
breaking the replacement
stool yet again.
Then he takes Carl to lunch
and feeds him an oyster off
of his fork [laughter].
The character Carl becomes
obsessed with Eros Mavro
after he leaves town
for his next engagement.
Carl repeats a mantra
in his head.
Plato makes Eros the
center of all emotions.
Carl latches onto the importance
that the older man links
to the word "sympathetic."
And when Eros Mavro
finally writes back,
it confirms all of
Carl's wishes.
Quote, "Eros writes
to him, 'I want you.
I dared not believe it before.
Come to me."' Considering
the sophomore outing
in creating writing, literally
sophomoric, I think it is okay
if we put aside the intentional
fallacy for a moment.
The story, which Bernstein
published in his collection
of writing findings in 1982, and
which exists here at the Library
in the Leonard Bernstein
Collection, demonstrates
that from Mitropoulos learned
to be simultaneously spiritual
and highly physical
nature of conducting,
an act involving
the entire body.
He also learned the importance
of feeling a real connection
with a fellow musician
and fellow gay man.
Mitropoulos's influence
can be seen not just
in Bernstein's leap-heavy
conducting,
and here we see some slides
of Mitropoulos midair while
conducting, but also in the way
that Bernstein conceptualized
conducting and its relationship
to sexuality and erotics.
Materials in the Library
of Congress's Leonard Bernstein
collection revealed the
vicissitudes of shame
and comfort
with which Bernstein viewed
his homosexuality and body,
and the relationship of these
relationship of these feeling
to his career as a conductor.
From his college years
throughout the 1940s,
Bernstein we now
know had hundreds
of male sexual partners.
Although the majority of these
relationships were casual,
Bernstein still saved
his correspondence
with many of these men.
They were filed away
by Helen Coates
who was Bernstein's
first piano teacher
and then later his personal
secretary and confidante.
One of the relationships that
seemed more than casual was
with a man named
Seymour Meyerson.
The two first met in 1945.
Helen Coates, in a letter
to Bernstein several years later
would even question Bernstein's
decision to marry by brining
up Meyerson as an example
of a partner who made
Bernstein truly happy.
Coates, Meyerson notes
in a letter to Bernstein,
would also confide in Meyerson
about Bernstein's
very busy sex life
and how she tried to manage it.
Based on the letters available
and trust which Bernstein
and Coates showed him,
Meyerson seems to have been one
of the more stable relationships
Bernstein had in the 1940s.
The two would continue writing
to each other even years
after they separated.
Like Bernstein, Meyerson also
married and had children.
And we wrote of the joys and
trials of family life and asked
after Bernstein's wife, Felicia.
He would also recall their
previous love for each other.
He wrote to Bernstein
of how one night,
while placing an older
sheet on the bed his wife
and he would shortly share,
he realized that it was the
same sheet upon which he
and Bernstein used
to regularly sleep.
Throughout the 1940s,
Bernstein also planned
to compose a musical on James
M. Cain's hardboiled novel,
Serenade , about
a tenor who falls
under the dangerous
influence of a gay conductor.
Kind of just ruined the plot.
I apologize.
By the end of the 1940s,
as Bernstein's prospects
for a major conducting position
increased, his datebooks
and correspondence here
at the Library revealed
that he was seeing a
psychoanalyst multiple times a
week in an effort to suppress
his homosexual desires.
Yet, even after his marriage
to Felicia Montealegre in 1951
and as late as 1954,
Bernstein was still hoping
to make a musical on
Cain's Serenade .
He couldn't let go of this
link between sexuality
and conducting just as he
couldn't let go of the photos
and letters of the men with whom
he had casual relationships,
the vast majority of
which are now available
to the public here
at the library.
Bernstein's connection
between conducting
and the erotic did make its way
into the public and
on prime time.
Consider his third Omnibus
Television Special on the "Art
of Conducting" in 1955.
After going over the elements
of musicianship a conductor
must have, Bernstein moved
on to the intangibles.
And this is as published
in his "IT Joy of Music .
He wrote, quote, "The conductor
must make the orchestra love the
music as he loves it.
It is not so much imposing his
will on them like a dictator;
it is more like projecting
his feelings around him
so that they reach the last man
in the second violin section.
And when this happens, when 100
men share his feelings, exactly,
simultaneously, responding
as one to each rise and fall
of the music, to each point
of arrival and departure,
to each little pulse, then there
is a human identity of feeling
that has no equal elsewhere.
It is the closest thing
I know to love itself.
On this current of love the
conductor can communicate
at the deepest levels with
his players, and ultimately
with his audience," end quote.
Bernstein called this focus
on an identity of feeling
through empathy with the
music throughout his life.
In outline, it is similar
to the erotic as theorized
by [inaudible] critic
Audre Lorde in her essay,
Uses of the Erotic,
Erotic as Power .
"[Inaudible] the
erotic quote comes
from sharing deeply any
pursuit with another person.
The sharing of joy, whether
physical, emotional, psychic,
or intellectual, forms a
bridge between the sharers."
Lord continues writing the
erotic is, quote, "the open
and fearless underlining
of my capacity for joy.
In the way my body stretches to
music and opens into response,
hearkening to its deepest
rhythms, so every level upon
which I sense also opens
to the erotically satisfying
experience," end quote.
As Bernstein aged and became
increasingly comfortable
discussing his work and sex
and sexuality without fear
of approach, he made
it clear that, for him,
conducting was a kind of erotic
transfer of power and pleasure.
Consider his words here.
>> There's a kind of
closeness that can be developed
with members of an orchestra.
It is a love affair in which you
and a body are breathing
together, closely together,
lifting and sinking together.
And I'm not making this sound
too lurid or too sexual.
It is, sort of, sexual.
But it's with 100 people.
>> Daniel M. Callahan:
Bernstein is clearly being a bit
of a bad boy there at
the end of the quote,
but I think that
his understanding
of conducting is
earnest and honest and --
even if it's kind
of playful here.
And if we take him seriously,
as I think we should,
I want to now refocus on
his body in performance
and see how it registers
these ideas.
Now, an obvious place to go
would be to a performance
of the Mahler Five
Adagietto which we just heard
as underscore to
Bernstein's comments.
Or perhaps to the final movement
of Mahler's Ninth Symphony ,
or as any diehard
Mahler fan would suspect,
to the final movement
of Mahler's Second .
And these are some photos
of Bernstein conducting
Mahler's Second Symphony .
Looking at these
photos, we might remember
that when Bernstein learned
that Mahler's Tenth
Symphony had been edited
and completed the
performance, he said,
quote, "I have one question.
Will it give me an orgasm"?
End quote.
Kind of a bad boy sometimes.
Today, however, I want us first
to consider Bernstein's
conducting of Tchaikovsky.
Bernstein programmed
and performed Tchaikovsky's
Pathetique,
the Sixth Symphony
with increasing relish
from the early 1970s on.
In 1986, on tour, he
partnered it on programs
with his own Serenade for
Solo Violin after Plato's
Symposium .
Some critics noticed a newfound
drama and level of commitment
in Bernstein's conducting
of the Pathetique .
Others disagreed.
After conducting the
New York Philharmonic
at UCLAs Royce Hall,
critic Martin Bernheimer
described the Bernstein's body
as, quote, "Shrugging, jumping,
sighing, soaring, gushing,
crouching, rocking, rolling,
bounding, bobbing, leaping,
jiggling, stabbing,
hunching, bumping, grinding,
and grunting," end quote.
Regarding the fire alarm
that interrupted Tchaikovsky's
Symphony, Bernheimer wrote,
quote, "A managerial
spokesperson refused
to confirm any connection
between the potential
conflagration
and the flamboyant
performance on the podium.
Nevertheless, this
was an undeniably,
uniquely flamboyant
performance," unquote.
Regarding Bernstein's
affect during the symphony,
Bernheimer wrote,
quote, "Emoting above
and beyond any call,
Bernstein acted out a series
of virtuosic charades.
He wiggled in moments
of agitation
as if he were auditioning
for the next Twyla Tharp
extravaganza," end quote.
Bernheimer ends his review by
comparing the concert's end
with post-coital affect.
Quote, "The Protagonist looked
picturesquely spent, ecstatic,
euphoric, wrung out as he basked
in the post climactic applause.
He also acted as if he and his
symphonic cohorts had somehow
succeeded in scaling at
least three Mount Everest's.
The exquisite ardor of the
moment could be expressed only
in an ever increasing
orgy of hugs and kisses.
I lift before the maestro
embraced the stagehands,"
end quote.
Bernheimer's depicture of
Bernstein as self-indulgent,
unnecessary, flamboyant,
over-emotional, and excessive
in bodily actions seems
to be motivated by more
than just the desire
to accurately cover
the performance.
Not all critics agreed however.
For example, take Tim Page of
the New York Times who wrote,
quote, "In the wrong hands,
Tchaikovsky can sound blatant
and vulgar, and listening
to his music can be a faintly
embarrassing experience,
like reading the intimate diary
of somebody you don't know.
There was nothing embarassing
about Mr. Bernstein's
Pathetique , although it was
as confessional
as any performance I have
ever heard," end quote.
The pathetic symphonist's
scores provided Bernstein an
opportunity to perform
professional climaxes galore.
Bernstein was particularly
convincing
when embodying late 19th century
sequences such as the one
at Rehearsal O in
the first movement
of Tchaikovsky's
Fourth Symphony .
In this clip, from the first
every Young People's Concert
Min 1958, "What Does
Music Mean?"
note the way that
Bernstein's whole body lands
on the beginning
of each iteration
of the sequenced motive.
Each time he says the word
"want" with an increasing sense
of attack and bigger bounce
back, as if charged by the rise
of the sequence, so much so
that by the last three wants,
he is throwing his head back
as if in convulsions of desire.
This will make more sense
as you watch the clip.
>> Okay, by saying
that it has the feeling
of wanting something very
badly that you can't have.
Did you ever feel that
you wanted something more
than anything else in the
world, and you said so,
and they said no,
you can't have it.
And you said, again, I want it.
And, again, they said no,
and again you said louder and
and more excited, I want it,
and again, louder, I want it,
until it seemed that something
would break in your head
and there's nothing
left to do but cry.
Well, that's like this music.
Listen.
[ Music ]
Finally something breaks
in your head and --
[ Music ]
-- and you cry.
>> Daniel M. Callahan: Now
that we have seen Bernstein
demonstrate his idea
of this music and the
charmed smile it elicited
from one young viewer in the
audience, let's compare it
to a filmed live
performance 12 years later.
Here, I want you to know
the same increased attacks
and the final throwbacks
of his head.
But also three other
things that occur
across Bernstein's
conducting on the podium.
First, the tiny look of ecstasy
signified by the open mouth
and the slump of the body at
the beginning of the sequence.
Two, Bernstein's use of
two hands on the baton
as he nears the climax
of the phrase.
And, three, the famous
Bernstein leap.
He gets airtime off of
the podium at the arrival
of the interrupting
stormy motive.
[ Music ]
Now that we've seen
three common features
in Bernstein's movement
vocabulary, and also the kind
of sense of his face
registering the music on it,
you might even say that
Bernstein faces the music,
meaning not that just he's
conducting the orchestra,
but he's also reflecting
the music on his face,
we can now turn to
something else.
Presumably this is something
that only [inaudible] orchestra
could see that's presumably not
for the audience even though he
knew he was being filmed here.
As bassist Orin O'Brien, who
was the first female member
of the New York Philharmonic who
was not a harpist, as she noted
about watching Bernstein
both from the auditorium
and the stage, she wrote, quote,
"From the audience as an usher
at Carnegie, I found it
difficult to take some
of Bernstein's gyrations and
dancing around the podium.
Upon joining the orchestra as
a bassist in 1966, however,"
she realized "his
movements weren't put
on for the audience's benefit.
He was simply living music
that he believed in so deeply."
In my remaining time with you,
I want us to consider
a few moments
where Bernstein's conducting
is clearly a set choreography,
one that repeats across years.
First, I'd like us to
consider the end of part one,
"The Dance of the Earth," from
Stravinsky's Rite of Spring .
I'd like to draw your
attention to the three levels
of Bernstein's forward jabs.
You'll notice him doing this.
And then, the very, very
dramatic kind of pause.
He's frozen at the very,
very end of part one.
So let's watch this from 1966.
[ Music ]
And now, six years later,
in 1972, the same passage.
[ Music ]
This is a very clear, I hope,
example of how exactly
the movement repeats.
And this happens
again in my next
and what will be
my final example.
Bernstein might leave us
almost fairly breathless
as we watch him conduct.
Bernstein himself also found
himself increasingly breathless.
At Alan J. Warner's memorial
service in New York City,
a bunch of Bernstein fans
knew he would be there.
And they gathered and they held
up signs saying, "We love you.
Please stop smoking."
And Bernstein, at the end
of his life, wrote, quote,
"The great thing about
conducting is you don't smoke
and you breathe in great
gobs of oxygen," end quote.
This seems kind of funny and
cute, but in August 1990,
Bernstein was to conduct the
Koussevitzky Memorial Concert
at Tanglewood with the
Boston Symphony Orchestra.
Because his emphysema
was kind of progressing,
they had to actually
line up oxygen tanks
and bring them backstage.
He was supposed to conduct
everything on the program.
But because he was very, very
ill, Carl St. Clair had to step
in and conduct Bernstein's
arias and barcarolles
which had just been
orchestrated by Bright Sheng.
When you read reviews
of this final concert,
newspaper writers all
kind of focus on the fact
that Bernstein was
very clearly ill.
Several of them mentioned his
coughing fit in the middle
of the third movement
of the Seventh Symphony
which would be the last work
that he would ever conduct.
Having read these stories
and also the biographies
if Bernstein, especially the
great Humphrey Bearden biography
and Tim Page's Concert Review,
and having not yet seen the film
that I will shortly show
you, I was incredulous
when my colleague at Boston
College, Sandra Hebert,
who was studying piano at
Tanglewood that summer,
insisted to me that Bernstein
performed his signature leap
at some point during
the Seventh Symphony .
And I said, you know,
Sandy, that's not possible.
He was coughing,
he's conducting.
You were just imagining
the great Bernstein,
which didn't square
with everything.
Furthermore, I had
heard the 1990 concert
on commercial recording
multiple times.
It's a recording that I love.
And hearing it, I didn't
believe that Bernstein --
the tempo was slower --
would have jumped in his
final conducting appearance.
The concert was very,
very special in 1990.
It marked 50 years since his
first professional appearance
at Tanglewood in 1940.
He conducts Britain's
[inaudible]
"Britain's Four Sea Interludes"
from Peter Grimes .
This is very important as well
because Bernstein
conducted the premier
of Peter Grimes in
the U.S. at Tanglewood.
And he also -- the final
work on the program
that he conducted was --
he conducted Bernstein's --
Beethoven's Seventh Symphony .
Beethoven's Seventh is
one of the two scores
that Bernstein had to
prepare for his audition
with Fritz Reiner at the
Curtis Institute in 1939.
It was also Beethoven's
Seventh programmed
for his first concert
as a Music Director
of the New York Philharmonic
in 1958.
It's a very -- a work
that's very, very near
and dear to Bernstein.
I'm going to show you
two sets of two clips.
The first will come from a
filmed performance of Bernstein
with the Vienna Philharmonic
in 1978.
And this is from the beginning
of the fourth movement
of Beethoven's Seventh
Symphony .
I want you to notice the nearly
identical movements in this clip
and in the following clip.
And this suggests that
Bernstein was really thinking
of conducting as a
kind of choreography,
or at least performing
it that way.
You'll notice that there's a lot
of elbow pumping that he does.
It's kind of like a dance in the
countryside imagined by someone
who lives in the city.
That sounds odd, but
I'll just show you
and I think you'll see
what I see pretty quickly.
[ Music ]
And now this is 12 years later
at Bernstein's final
appearance at Tanglewood.
[ Music ]
You can see the same
gestures here.
And I think that's pretty clear.
And then for my final
example of the talk
and of the evening tonight,
this is Bernstein's own score
of Beethoven Seven which
the New York Philharmonic has
digitized and put online
at the wonderful archives.
I wanted to use this
final passage
of descending 16th notes.
We're going to watch
Bernstein conduct it again
with the Vienna Philharmonic
in 1978 and you'll notice that,
again, that there's
this kind of wind-up,
a kind of pitch forward, a pitch
up and down, and then it ends.
And you'll just see
this right here.
[ Music ]
[ Applause and Cheering ]
And so again that same
wind-up and then the kind
of punch forward,
the up and down.
Here 12 years later in his
final conducting at Tanglewood.
[ Music ]
[ Cheering and Applause ]
Though physically exhausted,
and less than two months away
from his death on
October 14, 1990,
Bernstein conducted Beethoven's
Seventh Symphony that
afternoon with the
same choreography
that he had been
using for decades.
Like the dancers with
whom he had personal
and professional relationships
throughout his career,
like any musician,
Bernstein relied
on muscle memory he
had long internalized
after numerous performances.
Quote, "We are in a profound
and virtually inescapable
sense prisoners of our bodies,"
notes Gunter Schuller in his
book, The Complete Conductor .
Prisoners seems a bit strong.
If we take that out, it sounds
less bleak and more obvious.
"We are in a profound
and virtually inescapable
sense, our bodies."
Is the actions our bodies
perform the constant iterations
that come to identify us
as musicians and otherwise?
Then I suggest it is time
we fully acknowledge.
In Bernstein's final
performance, the vast majority
of the audience didn't recognize
that he was repeating the
choreography long stored
in his muscle memory, a
choreography predicated
on kinesthetic empathy
with a series of notes
that has been dubbed
"The Apotheosis
of the Dance" by Wagner.
Many in the shot at Tanglewood
even missed his small jump
at the beginning of the fourth
movement, but it was there.
The podium was still a dancing
place that Sunday afternoon.
But Bernstein's body took
up slightly less of it.
The podium also remained
a kind of safe space,
the place where Bernstein
could move shamelessly
in no small part because he
could temporarily forget many
of his other identities, even if
others could not, and focus only
on the music that
he sought to become.
As the musical community
celebrates Bernstein's 100th
anniversary in 2018, we might
also fully appreciate his
conducting as both
carefully choreographed
and instructively shameless.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
I believe we now have
time for questions.
There's a microphone
at the back.
We ask that you wait for
the microphone before asking
a question.
And if you could kindly identify
yourself for the microphone,
that would be appreciated.
>> Hi. I'm Bill Black.
I live here in Washington.
My question is, with all of this
energy and dance skill, did --
that he demonstrated with
music, did he demonstrate
that in other parts of his life?
Did he literally like
to go out dancing?
Did you see it in, you know,
his leisure time, sports,
anything else like that?
>> Daniel M. Callahan:
You know, there's --
if you look through the
photograph-like record
of Bernstein both here at
the Library of Congress,
at other archives, if you
plug in a Google Search,
you can see him that
he's a -- he has --
seemed to have had
a lot of energy.
People always say,
oh, I'm too busy.
You know, I'm really,
really busy.
Bernstein was really, really,
really busy in the 1940s
and across his life.
And, yes, you see
photos of him swimming,
running around with the kids
and the dog in the backyard.
There does seem to
be a lot of energy.
I probably need more
film footage about him
on the dance floor, like
a bar mitzvah or a wedding
or something to give you my full
kind of appraisal of his dancing
and social situations.
But I wouldn't be surprised
if there was quite
a bit of it, yes.
>> So as a non-musicologist,
have a very basic question.
I'm sold on everything
you've said.
I think it's terrific talk.
And I love the way it hangs
together and everything.
Can you help me understand
how other conductors --
because it seems to
me, it would seem
that muscle memory would
work for everybody.
So why didn't it
work for others.
What were they responding
to at the time what they
were responding, you know,
10 years apart, or why would
that be different
than what he did?
>> Daniel M. Callahan:
Good question.
So I don't mean to imply
or sell as you say.
I'm a musicologist,
but you are not.
I make no money.
I make a little bit,
but not enough.
So I didn't mean
to imply or to sell
that other conductors
weren't doing this.
Yes. I think I even say that,
you know, like any musician
in the final paragraph
of my talk,
Bernstein relied
on muscle memory.
However, there's this thing that
happens, both with conductors
and when we see people who maybe
do things with their bodies,
a certain dance move, whatever,
that are kind of more out there,
that are not, that we're not
used to, where we begin to talk
about the music, the movement,
in this case conducting,
as if it is disordered or
random or kind of outrageous.
My point here is that for all
of the talk of Bernstein's kind
of flamboyance and largeness,
there is a consistency,
one that we could kind
of expect, I think,
from most musicians who
have to get on stage
and give a performance
in front of an audience.
There are some conductors
who do seem --
I mean, of course there's many,
many styles of conducting.
There are some who
seem to kind of mix it
up from performance
to performance.
I gave the example
of Andris Nelsons
at the Boston Symphony Orchestra
because my first month in Boston
or second month in Boston in
2014 I took a bunch of students
over three different
nights to see him conduct.
And I was shocked at how
different the conducting was
when he put his right arm back
on the podium, when he went
up onto the balls of his feet,
when he would do this kind of --
he does this kind of
left-hand wave sometime.
And for someone who thinks
about people dancing and moving
around a lot, that kind
of stuck out to me.
And it was only then that
I began to think, wow,
for all of Bernstein's supposed
kind of craziness and dancing
around on the podium, he's
actually pretty darn consistent.
So that's kind of the
larger point and the context
for why I'm kind of saying.
It's also a great
excuse to watch a lot
of Bernstein clips
over and over again.
>> My name is Mather
Feiffenberger
[assumed spelling].
I live here in Washington.
Perhaps an obvious question,
but, yeah, very interesting.
You talk about how -- about
Bernstein's consistency.
This was also, would you say,
instinctive, unconscious?
I mean, if he were here now,
would he say to us, oh, yeah,
I planned it that
way, or would --
or you think he'd be surprised
at what you had found?
>> Daniel M. Callahan: While
I've done a lot of research,
I feel no way able to speak
for Leonard Bernstein
or what he thought.
I think that there,
there is a --
for a lot of people
there's a thing.
For example, the way you speak,
the way you move in general,
where you do certain things
kind of over and over again,
and you just get used to it.
And you maybe don't
even think about it.
In my hide, you know,
my voice sounds kind
of very specific and,
you know, deep and rich,
and then I hear a
recording of myself and I'm
like that's not what
my voice sounds like.
And I'm not thinking.
I'm not trying to sound
the way that I do.
It just is.
So I'm going to guess,
if I had to guess,
I would say that it's probably
partly just a matter of practice
and having run through
a score so many times.
So that's like many
things in life --
partly kind of done on
purpose and cultivated
and probably learned, and
partly in a way natural
or instinctive is the
word that you just used.
>> And last question, have
you been in touch, by chance,
with any of his children
and presented this research
and gotten their reaction?
>> Daniel M. Callahan: Right.
So Jamie Bernstein,
Bernstein's daughter,
who has a book coming out, or
just out right now, I believe.
>> Coming out in June.
>> Daniel M. Callahan:
Coming out in June.
I met her this past
February in Colorado Springs,
Colorado because
she, like her dad.
Is kind of in demand,
especially this year.
She had to leave the
morning of my talk,
but that night before the talk
I went over the talk with her.
I discussed it with her over
the a drink in the hotel lobby,
and I kind of focused
on this idea
of Bernstein's muscle memory.
And I said, you know,
it seems like, you know,
you dad would do a lot
of certain things over
and over again, and people
don't really kind of realize
that or give them credit.
And I say that partly because
I didn't really realize that,
until I sat down and watched
the videos over and over again.
And she said, that's the
exact same phrase that I use
when I talk about my
dad, muscle memory.
So, but, yes, I have met Jamie.
I've heard from Roger Englander
who was Bernstein's longtime
producer whom I did a series
of interviews with, an oral
history with, back in 2011.
That -- his son Alex is kind of
wonderful, so I do look forward
to meeting more of the
family as time goes on.
>> Kwon Kwon.
I'm a local resident.
I've got two questions.
You mentioned something
about three levels
when Bernstein was conducting
"Dances of the Earth",
Stravinsky's Rite of Spring .
Could you repeat those three --
>> Daniel M. Callahan:
Oh, right.
So there's -- both here
and in the day [inaudible],
I tried to pick examples
[finger-snap]
that you could kind of
very, very quickly grasp.
I know that many of you
have not seen these videos.
None of you have seen
them the 1990 film
of the final performance.
And you probably haven't
been in front of the mirror
in your bedroom repeating what
Bernstein does, like I do.
So there's a kind of thing in
both of these where the kind
of place where you kind of
-- when he's conducting,
he goes here, he goes down,
he goes up, and the kind
of specificity with which this
happens in both of these clips,
you see it again
in the Beethoven.
It's the exact same sequence.
An audience member in Colorado
Springs who was extremely lovely
and who I've been emailing with,
suggested that I might
consider having the two clips
side-by-side and
slowing down one of them.
I've done various work
with video editing,
taking kind of silent film of
modern dancers who were dancing
to a record, and
then synchronized it.
She suggested I should do
a split screen because --
especially to see the
time kind of winding
down on the clock over here.
We're at 8:11 p.m. I kind
of rushed through the end
of the talk a little bit.
My apologies.
But, so yeah, there's this --
there's a very kind of clear --
the kind of spots
that he's hitting
and what a dance analyst
would call his kinosphere.
If you imagine like
the DaVinci circle.
He goes to the same spots.
And this is, you know,
over a decade later.
So I hope that answers
your first question.
>> Second question is, since
he had his own choreography,
could he have choreographed
something
like West Side Story ?
No [laughter].
No. Because I could feel Jerome
Robbins in the grave doing
like you better say no quickly
[laughter], and put a box
around my name as it
is in the contract.
No. He couldn't.
However, I would guess Ben Stein
was intimate with, you know,
in working offstage
with many, many dancers.
Robbins especially.
You see these great
photos of Bernstein
at the piano trying things
out of West Side Story .
And Robbins is literally --
has his hands on his
shoulders touching him.
Dancers tend to be very,
very touchy people, you know?
You're sitting around
one moment.
[Inaudible] your dancer
is braiding their hair,
giving massages.
I think that Bernstein
was very, very comfortable
in this world because
he had to be.
He was working with
dancers a lot in the 1940s.
Do I think that being
around dancers a lot --
I mean, I hand out with
the dancers sometimes.
Does that mean that
I can choreograph
like a Morris Cunningham?
Absolutely not.
So that's my best guess on that.
>> Merin Alsop frequently refers
to his experiences
with Bernstein.
I wonder if you've
ever had a chance
to compare notes with her and --
>> Daniel M. Callahan:
That's an excellent question.
I'm so busy kind of
teaching and writing the book
that I'm currently
writing that I haven't.
But if you look at the recently
-- or not [inaudible] anymore.
The Bernstein, the last
interview with Jonathan Cott.
There's this wonderful
passage where Bernstein talks
about Merin Alsop and
says that you really have
to look out for this one.
She's going to kick some ass.
And so -- and you also see Alsop
in her own promotional materials
for Baltimore kind of
promoting how active she is.
You see her in [inaudible]
of the podium
but they had a video camera
follow her into the gym,
and you see Marin on the
treadmill kind of going because,
as she says, conducting
his a highly physical art.
It's many things.
It's also promotional
and dealing stoners
and programming with
the orchestra.
But it is ultimately a
body moving around trying
to create a certain
sound from a 100
or so people in front of you.
So I would relish
the opportunity
to interview Marin Alsop.
Marin, if you're watching on
YouTube, please contact me.
So, yeah. Thank you.
Very great question.
>> A couple of comments
and a question.
My first time to Tanglewood in
1972 was Bernstein conducting.
I have no recollection of what.
I just remember it was lovely.
It was magical.
And then I lived in
Boston for a long time
and it was [inaudible]
and the whole thing.
And just two weeks ago I went to
the Ken-Cen for the [inaudible]
and the L.A. Phil,
and I watched him
and I guess the Philharmonic
was great, but I don't remember.
I watched him and his hair flew
and his tails flew,
his baton flew.
He jumped several times
and I was in love.
My question is, when you were
here for your three weeks
and since then with the
material that you've researched
at the Library of Congress,
was there any great, wonderful,
magical moment of
something that you found
that you didn't know before?
>> Daniel M. Callahan:
Yes, a lot.
Yeah, a lot.
How much time do we have?
I mean there -- you know, at
the beginning of the talk,
Susan Vita, Chief Librarian,
said that there are, you know,
over 400,000 items
in the collection.
This is a archivist's -- I
worked in an archive in college.
One of my first kind of gigs
was being an Archival Assistant
at the Arnold Schoenberg
Center when I was younger.
Archivists often speak
of the linear feet
when they describe a collection.
And it's only a small
exaggeration to say
that Bernstein's would
circle the globe twice here
at the Library.
The personal letters
were amazing
because we have this very, very
kind of polished presentation.
This is someone who really
knows how to work a stage,
who knows how to work a
camera, which I do not.
And, you know, seeing him talk
kind of freely with people --
that was really, really amazing.
Seeing the archival
video that I got
from the wonderful Bridget Carr
at the Boston Symphony
Orchestra Archives.
That was a real aha moment.
I knew that there was video.
I knew it existed.
And it kind of confirmed
in a really,
really beautiful, poignant way.
I mean, when I first saw that
video I was sobbing, basically.
And then I realized this
is actually wonderful.
I mean this is -- even at
the very, very end, you know,
kind of, you know, dealing
with his own, you know,
physical fitness at that time.
Ben Stein is like still
on it, and is still doing
that same choreography.
So I think, yes, the first --
you know, when I was here
looking at all those letters,
that was very, very
overwhelming and kind of aha.
And then a few years
ago, now, in the basement
of the Boston Symphony
Orchestra, at the lower level,
their archives, seeing that
film for the first time.
Those were both kind of bookend
archival aha moments for me.
>> Hi. Susan Garfinkel.
I work here at the Library.
I guess a comment
and a question.
And I'll follow up and say that
-- like the last questioner,
I also went to Tanglewood in the
'70s as a child with my family.
And just [inaudible] like Marin
Alsop except that I did not go
onto become a wonderful
conductor.
I dreamed of becoming
a conductor
because of Leonard Bernstein.
And what's probably relevant
to you is, as a, you know,
a student who was studying
music, but was no, you know,
genius or anything, his
conducting made perfect sense
to me and without
knowing anything about any
of this critical
discourse about it.
It didn't -- it never occurred
to me that it didn't make sense
or that it wasn't
related to the music.
It helped me understand
the music
to watch him conduct the same
symphonies that I was playing
at summer camp or
in high school.
My question is, since you
started your talk mentioning
that he was often criticized for
doing too many different things
or trying to do too
many different things,
and I don't want to put
you on the spot too much,
but do you have an assessment
of how successful he was
as a conductor compared
-- I say that --
I think of him as
a conductor first
because that's how
I encountered him.
What is your sense of his
conducting in relation
to his other activities,
his television,
and his composing, and all that?
>> Daniel M. Callahan:
I can only answer --
I mean, this is not
my musicological
expertise speaking.
This is just me as
Daniel speaking.
For me, the -- it's hard
to separate all the things.
Number one, number two.
It -- since -- if like you
just put me on the spot,
if I had to pick which do
I think he kind of excelled
at more between conducting
and composing,
I would say conducting,
and I would say that partly
because it was what he was doing
[inaudible] so much of his time.
The man had to take a
sabbatical from conducting
because he was conducting
too much, and he wanted
to compose some stuff.
He had to say, New
York Philharmonic,
see you later like in a year.
I need to -- I need some
time to do other things.
I think because, just hours
per day, so much of it was --
more of it was conducting
than composing.
I would say that that in some
ways he probably saw his own
achievement as a
conductor rise more.
Of course there's tons of
stories about Bernstein feeling
like he did not live up to these
kind of impossible standards
that he set for himself
about composition, you know.
He wondered why are more people
not listening to my symphonies?
Why do more people not know
the "Serenade for Solo Violin?"
You know, everybody
knows West Side Story ,
and which is how
I first, you know,
came across Leonard
Bernstein as a child when --
before I was imitating him
conducting in the mirror
as an adult, as a child, I would
imitate the sharks on the street
with that beautiful low
shot on the Lego Lift.
So I guess partly because
he was -- he just had --
he was giving it more,
I would say, conducting.
That was a very long answer.
I don't -- it's like
picking, you know,
your favorite child
or something.
You don't want to do that.
But I would say conducting
I guess.
>> I'm Steve [inaudible].
The examples you gave were a --
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
-- that there are differences
in the way you approached
[inaudible].
>> Daniel M. Callahan:
Very, very good question.
And one that I have not
actually have had that known
or has actually asked me before.
I haven't -- to be very honest,
I haven't compared
enough repeat performance
of him conducting
the same things.
There is, of course,
a lot of footage
of Bernstein conducting
his own work.
For example, the recording
of West Side Story
with Carreras.
There's that horrible
scene where he has
to keep conducting the same
passage over and over again.
I would not be able
to use that to judge.
A very painful scene
to watch in some ways.
So I guess my short answer is
that's a very good question.
And I will get back to
you if you email me.
And I kind of go through
my file and think about it.
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
-- and I live in Washington,
D.C. And I think of Bernstein --
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
All right.
My question is, was he
more staid, more reserved
in conducting high or -- would
something such as the "Surprise"
in the 94th Symphony
have surely caused him
to execute the Bernstein Leap.
>> Daniel M. Callahan: Right.
I would say that if you compare
his conducting -- this is --
I did kind of maybe
cheat a little bit
by taking a late
19th century work
and an early 20th century work,
both of which are
very loud and big.
I would say that if you
look at his conducting
of classical composers
-- Mozart, Haydn --
that actually I don't --
it's not necessarily as a
whole more reserved, actually.
Obviously you don't have the
reason to do things like you do
at the conclusion of the
"Dance of the Earth" at the end
of Part One of the
Rite of Spring .
If you conducted
Haydn like that,
there might be a slight mismatch
or you would get a very
interesting sounding Haydn.
I don't know.
But in terms of the kind of
engagement and the full use
of the body, I would
say that kind
of occurs throughout the rep.
Yes. So, yeah.
Does that answer your question?
>> Yes.
>> Daniel M. Callahan:
Thank you.
>> Well, I'd like to thank
our speaker one last time.
If you could join me in that.
Thank you, Professor Callahan.
[ Applause ]
>> Daniel M. Callahan:
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.